hello everyone in my previous video you
have seen young Mishra battling it out
with former world champion Anatoly
Karpov and he wasn't too happy about
losing on time but he recovered pretty
pretty fast and I saw I saw most of you
in the comments see were you were very
happy for young Misha but some of you
were actually saying that a
three-year-old can play chess like that
and I just wanted to say that the
four-year-old Capablanca for example
there wasn't a single chess master in
the entire in the entire Cuba that could
beat the four-year-old kappa blanka with
the queen odds so i mean there are
that's why they're called chess
prodigies and this is the game I told
you in my previous video that I would
show this was played a couple of days
ago I think it was four days ago where
the four-year-old now four-year-old
Misha Misha osipov is playing against 95
year old Grandmaster Yuri Auerbach and
Yuri our buck is actually the oldest
Grandmaster in the world today at 95
years old and I always like to mention
that it was against Yuri over back that
me hotel won his Grandmaster title he
played the famous Belgrade gambit with
the white pieces and well everybody had
to spend a lot of time to to get out of
the opening safely and well in the end
our but lost in time and Misha got his
Grandmaster title but this is game Misha
was appalled against Yuri arbok Misha
has the white pieces and the 95 year old
Grand Master has the black pieces we
have E 5 d4 sorry
c5 saw the Sicilian defense Knight to f3
tonight to c6 d4 we have a seek after
sandy for tonight capture 74m Knight to
f6 and we have Knight to c3
we have d6 and Misha Misha goes for
Bishop to b5 not to Bishop to c4 the
Fischer favorite we have Bishop to d7
now Knight captures and c6 b captures
and c6 and Bishop to c4 and ok this is
all this is all great white is still
better here so Misha is doing great we
have e 6 and the mission castles by 57
bayou
rook to e1 and we'll have castles Bishop
to d2 and okay maybe Bishop f4 was a
more active move but mission knows what
he's doing
everybody plays rook to e8 and only now
Mitchell plays Bishop to f4 he probably
saw that now that rock went from f88
that now Bishop f4 was a better square
for the bishop and he might as well be
correct as the engine is giving white
the advantage here we have d5 by our
Bach he captures on d5 seek after Sun d5
and Bishop to d3 and here we have Queen
to b6 attacking that B to pawn
we have b3 defending and now rook to c8
attacking the c3 Knight Misha plays
Knight to e2 and we have Bishop to c5
and in this position well our box does
get an edge as now he's attacking this
f2 pawn and well ameesha probably should
have played something like Bishop to g3
to defend this f2 pawn with the bishop
but he decided to play rook to f1 and
this is actually a blunder by young
Misha as our Bach played a 5 we have
Bishop to g5 and as the bishop has no
other choice but to move now our back
gets this move with the tempo he gets
efore and he traps maecius Bishop here
on d3 so there is no way to save the
bishop and Misha plays Bishop captures
and f6 we have he captures on d3 Queen
captures on d3 and G captures on f6 and
here we have Queen to f3 our Bach plays
Bishop back to f8 and this is this is a
Misha's next move is pretty I I don't
know what what to call it
it is a blunder but how such a blunder
was made and made I really don't know as
was it low time control was it too much
people for for a youngish or something
he played with Queen captures on f6 and
of course now arbok
can capture the Queen on f6 it's it's
practically a free Queen and auerbach
probably said that human
this Queen captures an f6 as they say
Auerbach has a very very poor sight he
maybe he thought the Queen was defended
I don't know but maybe he just decided
that after he saw Misha cry after that
game against Anatoly Karpov that he
doesn't want to make Misha cry again
so our Bach played Bishop to g7 now
kicking the Queen out of f6 and the
Misha play between capture some b6 we
have a capture some v6 and now we should
please rotate the c1 to defend this c2
pawn
although his Knight is hanging an e2 so
and here our Bach plays rook captures
and c2 and our box says that our box
said that he thought that Mitchell
played rook to d1 that he couldn't see
so far to the end of the board and he
thought Mitchell played rook to d1 and
he thought okay it's a free porn but me
she just captured this rock so Road
captures on c2 and after our Bach plays
Bishop to e6 Auerbach immediately
resigned as this is a winning endgame
for white but I don't know even though
our box says that he he kind of missed
that rope c1 he thought that the rock
was on d1 I think he really wanted young
Misha to have this win and probably
thought that this would really motivate
the little fellow to continue pursuing
his just career as well before before
that one that happened before that rook
to f1 move and I don't really know what
the time controls were here
he probably he probably wanted young
Misha to win and it was a it was a it
was a beautiful sight I mean the
four-year-old at playing against a 95
year old there's really I don't think
there's a sport where this can happen
and where you know generations can get
together like this and and play
competitively and yeah I will put as in
the previous video I will put the link
in the description of this video so you
can watch the entire video of of the
event of young Misha playing yuri
overbook and yeah it's a it's it's a
it's a beautiful game and Misha doesn't
really look
the three-year-old heal the last year he
looks it looks really dangerous and he's
ready to play some serious jest even
though he did make some poor judgment
judgment moves this game so yeah that's
it for this video I would like to thank
Frank Fitzgerald and Gilmour Rowley
thank you thank you for your
contribution guys and the two of you are
I'm pretty sure the two of you are one
of the first people who have contributed
to my channel and this is your second
time contributing to my channel so I do
guess you kind of enjoy the content I'm
creating and that makes me very happy
and I really appreciate it so yeah
that's it for this video I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon